time's almost up on this hour but first
let's share one last story I'm obsessed
with this is what I'm liking
[Applause]
in retirement a former Montana school
teacher is doing just that in the most
incredible way she turned a van into a
mobile bookstore and she road trips
across the country sharing her love of
reading with strangers and making
endless Friends Along her journey we
have her on the line right now dialed in
from her traveling bookstore parked in
Eureka Montana everybody say hello to
Rita watching on kxlyn
hi Rita
hello so this is really unique so what
made you want to do this well I live in
a really small town in Montana at 1500
people and I realized if I wanted to
open a bookstore that it couldn't be a
brick and mortar bookstore or I'd go
broke so brainstormed and came up with
the idea of a traveling bookstore I can
take it where there's people festivals
farmers markets cities and set up and I
have customers and when I'm not on the
road then I just stays parked in my my
driveway so I've been doing it for about
eight years now and I've traveled all
across the country I've been to the east
coast three times down the West Coast a
bunch of times just came back from a
trip in the the mountains and Great
Plains so it's yeah it's it's a
wonderful experience I carry about six
to seven hundred volumes of books in the
bookstore and then I have some storage
in the back for for extra books for when
I'm on the road for a long period of
time you've got it figured out that's
rent free that's
your doubt I would love I love
bookstores and I love like small
boutique kind of things too because you
never know what you'll find in them so I
would adore this if I ran into you I'm
going to find you but you say this isn't
about making money though right right I
do make enough money to cover gas and
tires and insurance and fees things like
that when I am on the road so um I say
that the bookstore pays for itself and I
pay for myself so that's
that's the way it works
um for the kids I really feel like books
should be affordable so I make all the
kids books a dollar whether they're
picture books or chapter books and that
way kids can afford it if they come to a
farmer's market and they want to buy
other things they can afford a book so
it's so cool
I love my kids would adore it as well
thank you so much Rita this is really
cool you're doing I'm liking your post
right now right
and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly Unstoppable people just like
you ma'am so they're going to be writing
you a check for a thousand dollars how
does that sound
thank you so much now thank you so much
Rita and thank you to all our guests
this hour George and Maya Lopez Allison
Sweeney Maddie Zach and Jake Miller
y'all have a great day and if it's not
train changes
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]